Harry Potter Quidditch Champions what
the heck's going on with it why isn't
there more hype that was a question one
of you recently asked in our Discord and
it got me thinking that's a really good
point question here from Apollo said has
there been any sort of estimated release
date for this game I feel like I haven't
seen much of this in comparison to all
the stuff we got for Hogwarts Legacy
well on one hand Apollo is right we had
so much hype and build up to Hogwarts
Legacy we speculated about that game for
quite literally years whereas quidditch
Champion she just kind of got dropped in
announced out of nowhere but I think
there's a big reason that we haven't
seen so much hype behind it and it's
because a lot of people have played the
game we know they just recently did a
third play test for the game and anyone
who participated in these play tests not
naming any names anyone who played the
game would then no longer be able to
make videos talking and speculating
about what may be in the game because
they would know some of what is in the
game if you're wondering why you haven't
seen a lot of videos on quidditch
champions from The Usual Suspects
probably assumed that there is a very
good reason for that now one thing we
can talk about out is the publicly
available information and we can
absolutely speculate on a possible
release date so as I mentioned we know
they just did a third play test could
they do more they absolutely could and I
think that really depends on the type of
feedback that they're getting which I
expect that's exactly what they're doing
right now is gathering feedback from all
these play tests they've been doing and
I think that is also going to have a
direct impact on when the game releases
you know clearly they had at least
somewhat of a playable state of the game
ready to go that they felt confident
sharing with a lot of people in a play
test so if all the feedback they get
from that is incredibly positive this
game is the best thing we've ever played
I don't think you need to change
anything then we could be looking at a
release date very soon then I think
another possibility would be a sort of
Middle Ground where it's like okay we've
got a good core game but maybe there are
some things we need to tweak here and
there it's going to take some time maybe
a couple months maybe another year and
then there's a third option which is one
that none of us want to see and that's
the game is like in a really bad State
and needs a lot of work and it's going
to go away for a couple of years and
then finally come back hopefully that's
not the case now if we want to speculate
when they would like to get this game
out of course they would want to get it
out by the holidays of this year now if
we take all those things into
consideration I think there's another
possibility that we have to consider and
that's the fact that they could actually
release this game as a public beta and
we see games doing this all the time now
especially when it comes to multiplayer
games because it really gives the
developers an opportunity to stress test
in a huge environment when you get a lot
of people playing in terms of a pricing
structure I do still lean toward this
being a free to play game with
microtransactions throughout which I
know people hear that word and they
immediately want to tune out but I do
think it can be done correctly and in a
way that's not super invasive to gamers
in a way that's not a pay-to-win
mechanic as far as release date
predictions go the more I think about
this I actually could really see the
beta thing happening and if that happens
we could see a release potentially as
early as this summer back to Hogwarts
day maybe but if they want to go the
other route and say hey let's release
this game in a fully complete State we
do not want to go the beta route then I
could see it being another six months to
a year before it releases I do think at
the end of the day though this is a game
that we're gonna see within the next
year for sure I don't think it's going
to be a Harry Potter magic Awakening
situation where it goes away for a while
nah don't think we're gonna see that
here I still think one of the most
fascinating questions is how how exactly
this game is going to play and how
they're going to handle the rules of
quidditch I actually already have a
video breaking down all the
possibilities you can check that one out
next on the right side of your screen if
you missed it as always thank you all so
much for watching I'll talk to you again
soon